In this unit,
you'll return to the two classes
that you covered last time as well.
You'll look again at Sebastian Thrun's
introduction to Machine Learning class,
and Charles Isbell and
Michael Littman's Machine
learning class from Georgia Tech.
Along the way you'll cover
different methods for
doing Unsupervised Learning like
clustering and feature selection.
We really want you to focus on
three things during this unit.
One, we again want you to focus
on how Unsupervised Learning
fills in that model building gap from
the original Machine Learning work flow.
Two, we want you to understand how to
compare different models developed using
Unsupervised Learning for their relative
strengths and relative disadvantages.
But, three, and most importantly for
Unsupervised Learning, we want you to
understand the different kinds of
conclusions that Unsupervised Learning
can generate, the different kinds
of problems that it addresses and
how it differs from Supervised Learning.
So you should come away from this unit
with an understanding not only of
how to do Unsupervised Learning, but
how it can address different
things from Supervised Learning.